winning is not supposed to be fair life  is not fair there's nothing that's going  to guarantee you  that win it's but the only thing that's  going to guarantee that loss  is if you don't get in this race how  many people and you talk about this all  the time  about the fears and the emotions and  like you know just  getting just going for it just like here  it is  look at yourself you've moved  three different times in probably the  last six  months for whatever reasons you've had  all right and you literally packed up  and moved like here i'm going here i'm  going here  you got people that will move themselves  out of a chair you've literally moved  families lives  and there's literally a fear behind  every single one of those but there's no  doubt